the subtle through it our first employer
gets the whole shape tell me the
important points you can go right away
before you know anything about the shape
of it tell me the points okay the origin
because again we're looking at we did
the square they're going to the square
root here the square root of 0 is 0 this
other square root of 00 and lastly this
square root is your 0 what else I am and
x equals playing to you get y equals 1
and the square in one is still one okay
so far so good on my analysis I have no
other important point to notice now what
can you tell me so I got Johnny or
chicken here right and the reason for
that was because it's not the car it's
not that I can't cuz I work too many
many quality coz square root of negative
values you can take the square root of
David values it's just the thin not real
they're not on this play you know on
some other claim it don't let me ever
hear you say you can't you can okay you
want them to know you can I just don't
worry can you say you can't display them
on this grill like how do ya if your
next word is display yes you can say you
can't but I much prefer you to say that
they're just not on this graph they
exist you can and then just somewhere
else that's all alright so I'm not going
to display anything from PI to 2 pi so
therefore what's interesting is in here
tell me what's going on
okay so the square sine X will always be
above this blue line over here because
what is it that tells me it's always
going to be above all that work tendon
or just beer instead we call is these
days are between 9-1 right and therefore
when you like the number this came from
had to be higher right so I've had to be
low us that's why the square root is
going to be higher right remember the
example I gave you was the square root
of a quarter I always go back to this
right um you've got 83 the important
just practically when you are confused
about something cuz you're so much
knowledge in your head go back two
examples that you know really well okay
so one example that people get really
badly even though you've worked your
years ago is when you factorize this
people get confused between the
factorization that pair of numbers
versus the Bruce right and people think
our way that means the roots of 2 & 3 no
way the factorizations to entry wait
which ones which okay now I always come
back to this one because I can do this
in my sleep and so oh well this means
that if it's equal to 0 then X is
negative 2 and morning through okay so
this is my example that I go always go
to pointers the square root go up or
does it go down well this is the square
root of one on the square root for which
is a humph yes so a quarter goes it goes
up now it does not always want to stay
above but there's one more thing I want
to notice right do you remember when we
did X versus the square root of x right
I noted something we was happening the
origin what's happening the origin very
good you've got no gradient okay you
guys vertical tangent there the grating
here is one the grading here is also one
so in fact you're going to get the same
vertical kind of tangent there that you
got over here okay and then the rest of
it you've got to meet up to there so
you're going to get this shape and then
you gotta go from PI to 2 pi you do the
same thing but in Reverse so you get
this show
that's it that's the whole square root
of sighs at least in the domain that
we're interested now just before we
leave this guy I mentioned at the
beginning of sometimes you link out to
this okay now this is very closely
related to this in what way are these
two related how would you get from what
operation would you apply to get from
this like this like you take the square
root of sites but you guys know if you
have something like x squared equals 25
and you take the square root both sides
you don't just get x equals 5 g you get
good so over here say deal right if this
you want to write in this form that you
have to have a plus/minus right so
therefore if i asked you to draw y
equals the square root of sine X if it's
dead I asked you to draw this ok then I
can take the square root both sides
which gives me this so what we're going
to add the flu I'm think back to the
first lesson you did on photographing
which was this means I've got the other
side as well which is down here ok now
it's actually not quite a circle because
because the reason I know it's not a
circle is because going this way the the
we call this is a semi no we call to the
minor axis okay that distance is 20 or
the distances it's too right what this
distance it's pi very very warm so
therefore it's not circular but it looks
pretty circular doesn't it it's
elliptical okay which is kind of neat
and in fact if you go to two desmos and
you put in this okay you're going to get
your axes and then you're just going to
get a bunch of bubbles this one and then
this one and then all the way off
because of course is periodic right okay
yes question
hon you talking about here that pyre at
X equal PI to PI to PI over here okay
yes ah that's a great question very nice
and technical if you were asked to drive
is still really good just note this if
you are asked to draw y equals the
square root of sine X like I have done
and you are asked to do it from not to
pint okay you will notice over here and
over here I haven't done any closed or
hollow circles close up field or hollow
circles because like when you've got a
balance it's like will you end there you
in there okay it's done you don't get to
say anything special but as it's been
very Christian footed out over here at 2
pi the next cycle begins so in fact you
can take that value but I'm na Dori the
rest of it so I have to say something
here indicate yes partly reference is
there and if you did that just for the
sake of completeness you've got one
filled circle I kind of cleaned up
pretty the rest of them just because
we'd have one filled circle and not have
any the rest of them okay so that's what
it would look like